Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Nous sommes en 2050,
quelque part sur Terre.
Vous êtes en consultation
parce que votre montre connectée,
votre sentinelle,
vous a averti qu’il y avait un problème
pour votre santé, un danger.
D’ailleurs, depuis quelque temps,
vous vous sentez un peu fatigué.
Vous avez quelques douleurs
et vous ne pouvez pas vous l’expliquer.
Votre médecin,
après avoir échangé avec vous,
vous propose de prendre une micro-capsule.
Comme aujourd’hui, vous pourriez prendre
une micro-gélule de paracétamol.
Dans cette capsule sont embarqués :
un avatar de votre médecin avec toute
la connaissance qu’il peut avoir,
de quoi faire des analyses sanguines
et d’autres humeurs,
de quoi faire des images
de ce qu’il se passe à l’intérieur,
et même une pharmacie.
Cette micro-capsule, c’est vous
qui la dirigez par la pensée,
la faites voyager dans votre corps
pour la faire aller là où
vous sentez que vous souffrez.
Vous êtes examiné,
exploré, voire traité
presque sans vous en rendre compte.
En tout cas, sans voir
le fil de votre vie interrompu.
Bien sûr, ce scénario
relève de la fiction,
voire de la science-fiction,
tel qu’en 1966, dix ans après la naissance
de l’intelligence artificielle,
Richard Fleischer, dans «Le voyage
fantastique» avait miniaturisé
une équipe de savants pour qu’ils puissent
voyager à l’intérieur du corps
d’un de leurs collègues
qui avait été empoisonné
et de sorte, le guérir.
Revenons sur Terre, en 2021.
Nous sommes déjà en transition
vers une médecine 3.0.
Le patient connecté qui veut piloter
sa santé et développer son autonomie.
Mais d’ailleurs, finalement, qu’est-ce
que c’est la santé, à quoi ça sert ?
La santé, ce n’est pas un but dans la vie.
Je ne crois pas que quiconque
dans cette assemblée, ni même ailleurs,
ne se lève le matin en disant : «Tiens,
aujourd’hui, je vais faire de la santé !»
Ou : «Je vais être en santé».
Non : on se lève le matin pour faire
quelque chose, pour agir,
pour accomplir un rêve, une ambition.
La santé, c’est une ressource de la vie,
de ma vie, de nos vies.
Et je vous propose une définition
qui a été élaborée et énoncée
il y a une trentaine d’années par
deux grands médecins de santé publique,
Mounier et Deschamps, et qui dit ceci :
«La santé, c’est la capacité physique,
avec le corps,
psychique, avec le mental,
sociale,
d’une personne de pouvoir
agir dans son milieu
et d’accomplir les rôles qu’elle entend
assumer d’une manière acceptable pour elle
et pour le groupe auquel elle appartient.
C’est donc une définition
dynamique, ouverte,
la définition d’une santé déjà connectée.
Plus tout seul, ensemble, acceptable
pour le groupe dont je fais partie.
La maladie, c'est l'inverse, totalement.
Vous êtes isolé,
reclus à l’intérieur de votre corps.
Il y a une distance qui s’installe
entre les autres et vous.
Vous n’êtes plus du même monde :
vous êtes d’un autre monde.
Et ça, c'est difficile.
Vous êtes le seul à le vivre.
Alors, comment faire pour être
et revenir dans le monde ?
Et le fait de se sentir
dans un autre monde,
c’est valable aussi bien
que vous soyez malade,
que vous croyiez avoir une maladie
ou que vous risquiez d’avoir une maladie.
Je vais vous raconter ce qui
m’est arrivé personnellement.
Ce n'est pas une histoire, c'est ma vie.
Il y a dix ans, j'ai cru que j'avais
une maladie grave, gravissime.
Parce que les signes que j’avais
me disaient, dans ma tête,
avec mon algorithme 0.0 ou 1.0 :
« Ce n’est pas la bonne pioche. »
Qu’est-ce que j’ai fait, moi,
Patricia, tout médecin que je suis ?
Je suis allée sur Internet, comme tout
le monde, pour voir ce qui s’y disait.
Pourquoi ?
Pour avoir de l’information,
mais surtout pour me rassurer,
parce que j’avais peur.
Et bien sûr, ça n’a pas marché.
Je n’ai pas été rassurée.
Alors si j’avais eu cette micro-capsule,
oui, je l’aurais prise,
pour qu’elle me dise :
«Tiens ! Avec la tête, que ça a,
la prédiction pour que ce ne soit pas
sympathique, c’est de tant,
et pour que ce soit bien,
c’est autre chose.
Ça m’aurait rassurée
et diminué mon angoisse parce que
l’angoisse, ça vient de l’incertitude
et ça aurait rassuré mes médecins aussi.
Cette possibilité que donnent les datas,
finalement, pourquoi la refuser ?
Cette possibilité de diminuer
l’incertitude et l’angoisse,
car je ne l’ai pas dit,
j’ai oublié de vous le dire,
entre le moment où j’ai eu les signes
et le moment où j’ai su
que finalement,
ce n’était pas si grave que ça,
vous savez combien de temps s’est passé ?
Neuf mois, le temps d’une grossesse.
Au deuxième trimestre
de ma grossesse de maladie,
j’ai su que c’était un peu mieux engagé.
Mais quand même.
Et là, je me suis dit : «Mais mon Dieu,
si je n’étais pas de la partie,
si je n’étais pas du milieu,
je serais devenue folle.»
Alors, j’imagine ce que ça peut être
pour quelqu’un qui n’a pas d’éléments.
Piloter ma santé,
qu’est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Ça veut dire ce qu’on m’a dit
un jour en formation.
On était plusieurs professionnels de santé
et le psychologue qui animait
la formation a dit :
«Quand je vais voir un médecin,
je lui demande de s’occuper de la maladie.
Et moi, je m’occupe du malade.»
Et c’est ça, piloter sa santé
pour pouvoir accomplir les choses
de manière acceptable pour soi.
Alors, à quoi ça sert
l’intelligence artificielle ?
Ça sert aux soignants
et ça sert aux patients.
Ça sert aux soignants.
Imaginez telle que je suis,
que je sois Néo dans Matrix
et que, en un clic, [souffle]
toute l’histoire de la médecine,
des siècles et des siècles me soient
accessibles, utilisables
et je saurais m’en servir.
Pour les patients, c’est enfin
avoir accès à un monde inconnu.
Comprendre ce qui se passe dans ce truc,
ce morceau de vie,
connaître pour pouvoir comprendre
et pour pouvoir agir avec son corps,
piloter sa vie.
Pourquoi s’en priver ?
D’ailleurs, les gens ont déjà commencé.
Vous connaissez ces montres connectées
qui vous donnent une idée
de votre rythme de sommeil
de sorte que vous puissiez organiser
vos journées en conséquence.
Les diabétiques connaissent des systèmes
qui permettent d’avoir
le taux de sucre dans le sang,
qui renvoient l’information à un logiciel
qui est en relation
avec la pompe à insuline.
Ça existe déjà.
Toutes ces données, il va falloir
apprendre à les gérer,
à les décrypter, à les transformer,
à les utiliser,
à dire oui, je veux
les transmettre, ou pas,
et c’est ça qui sera le garant
de la sécurisation de ces données.
Et pour cela, il faut un compagnonnage,
un compagnonnage entre la personne,
le soigné, le patient,
et l’équipe soignante.
C’est pour ça que plutôt que de parler
d’intelligence artificielle,
je vous propose,
comme me l’a dit un patient,
je le cite, Denis m’a dit : «Moi, plutôt
que de parler d’intelligence artificielle,
je préfère parler
d’une intelligence accompagnée.»
Accompagner, c’est guider,
accompagner, c’est ensemble.
C’est une équipe qui va converger
dans une direction,
celle que je peux donner.
Alors, la promesse de cette intelligence
accompagnée, quelle est-elle ?
Elle est de nous permettre de faire
un pari sur une confiance préservée,
renforcée entre des acteurs qui vont
apprendre à échanger sur des données
fiables, confrontées, corrélées.
Et c'est la porte ouverte
à la médecine 4.0.
Cette médecine des 4P :
prédictive, participative,
préventive, personnalisée.
La médecine prédictive ?
Ce n’est pas Madame Irma,
ce n’est pas : «je vois, je vois.»
C’est une médecine qui s’appuie sur
la puissance faramineuse de calcul
des algorithmes pour donner des données
précises et pertinentes.
C’est donc une médecine précise.
Là, avec ma micro-capsule,
vous vous rappelez,
quand je pensais avoir
quelque chose de grave,
ça me dit, avec la tête que ça,
là où c’est positionné,
comment ça se passe,
tu as 99 % de chances que ce soit bien,
je prends la bonne alternative.
Une médecine préventive.
Préventive parce qu’elle va me protéger.
Elle va me protéger parce que
les messages vont être adaptés.
Femme d’un certain niveau d’éducation,
habitant à tel endroit,
avec certaines habitudes de vie,
voilà le message qui va t’intéresser,
qui va avoir un sens.
Donc une médecine protectrice.
Une médecine participative.
Parce que je suis dedans,
je suis dans ma vie,
je suis totalement engagée dans ma vie.
Et plutôt que d’être un, une toute seule
à souffrir dans mon coin,
je passe à l’échelle du milliard,
pas de souffrants, mais la communauté
dont je fais partie.
Quelqu’un, quelque part
à l’autre bout du monde,
vit quelque chose qui relève
du même événement que moi.
Et je n'en connais ni le niveau
social ni la culture.
Mais nous formons cette communauté.
Je peux agir de façon acceptable pour moi
et la communauté dont je fais partie.
Quatrième P -
Donc c’est une médecine partagée.
Quatrième P, c’est la médecine
personnalisée.
Personnalisée, parce qu’avec toutes
ces données, c’est comme une boucle,
je veux recevoir.
Si je veux recevoir, il me faut ouvrir
la main pour donner,
Donner tous ces éléments qui vont me
permettre d’avoir des données précises
et qui vont devenir précieuses.
Et cette médecine, elle va être pilotée.
Pilotée, dans mon cas, c’est dire :
« J’accepte d’être opérée ou non.
Je veux surseoir à l’intervention
et s’il faut réajuster,
on réajustera ensemble. »
Que voulons-nous ?
Nous voulons pouvoir continuer
à écrire l’histoire de nos vies.
Nous voulons pouvoir continuer d'écrire
l'histoire de notre espèce sur Terre.
Nous voulons pouvoir continuer à écrire
l'histoire de la vie sur Terre.
Alors osons le pari de cette médecine
et de cette intelligence accompagnée
qui est basée et portée par une relation
de confiance rénovée,
renforcée entre des acteurs
à la fois autonomes et interdépendants
pour une médecine prédictive et précise,
préventive et protectrice,
participative et partagée,
personnalisée et pilotée.
Et ainsi, nous pourrons permettre
à la Terre, notre vaisseau,
de continuer pour des milliards
d’années encore,
une odyssée qu’elle a entamée
il y a des milliards d’années.
Rendez-vous en 2050.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)